[Laughter]
no you you drive i
shoot
i'm not hearing you you're driving oh he
can't he's lost his hearing aid
oh no oh man oh
you're coming track dracula
oh my god these guys i have not come to
play
well they haven't cut yet oh my god this
is gonna be sick
this show's gonna be crazy oh [ __ ] are
you kidding me i have oh my god whoa
this cinematography no
i'm using this one
do
[Music]
come on come on
wow
[Applause]
welcome back to new rockstars marvel's
hawkeye is days away which will throw
clint barton and gay bishop into an
avengers level threat with nothing but a
bow and arrow nothing makes sense so as
we shall ask after every episode of
hawkeye this holiday season
what the hawk
this is inside marvel and from now on
until the end of the year this will be
our official after show for hawkeye on
disney plus i'm eric boss i'm here with
mt
dude hawkeye is coming up i'm so excited
i've been wanting a matte fraction
adaptation so badly and we're finally
getting it it's gonna be dope
from all the promo footage we have seen
for this show it just looks so funny so
well shot such great action it's gonna
be fun to just like cozy up on the couch
and just put this show on every right i
can't wait for it it's a good christmas
show it looks very it's a great
christmas show now so far for hawkeye
we've seen a couple of these trailers
promos this extended scene released
during disney plus day but mt and i are
going to break down everything you need
to tell going into this series including
the mystery of who is echo the new
spin-off disney plus series that was
announced last week what is that show
going to be about why is echo going to
be so important in this plot well before
we get into that our merch partners at
epic hero shop are launching a brand new
latest obsession shirt inspired by
hawkeye that you got to get over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and when you get
the hawkeye shirt you will get the added
option to write in a custom shout out
that will appear during the bottom of
the screen during these hawkeye after
shows so this is a limited edition shirt
go grab one before it runs out uh but mt
what's our first question heading into
hawkeye well bro since this is the
pre-show the question's gotta be what
the hawk is the hawkeye series even
about let's break this down together mt
so hawkeye is gonna be a six-episode
mini-series following clint barton
hawkeye jeremy renner of course teaming
up with kate bishop haley steinfeld
around christmas time in new york city
after the events of avengers end game
when kate shows up in clint's old ronin
assassin gear from avengers end game
that ends up entangling them both in
some kind of dispute with the criminal
underworld this is being directed by
rhys thomas one of the greats from the
snl broadway video operation who seems
to be embracing comedic holiday action
comedies in the vein of lethal weapon
and die hard i'm super excited to see
this tone back in the mcu it's one of
the things i loved about iron man 3 just
a a classic christmas action buddy
comedy and i think this hawkeye series
is going for that absolutely we should
just have one christmas show or a year
like just to have a christmas mcu thing
i think it'd be great we're just on
holiday we've got the the guardians of
galaxy holiday special next year uh and
then yeah every time we should have
something christmasy yes this series is
adapting the 2012 comic run by matt
fraction the dude go read everything
that he writes and david aha and we'll
focus on clint struggling with hearing
loss and facing the gang called the
tracksuit dracula or the tracksuit mafia
russians who end every sentence with bro
like what's going on bro bro what you
doing bro give us the money bro bro yeah
you're moving bro oh
pivot bro pivot
bro
what's going on bro
and there'll also be appearances by the
best character in the show lucky the
pizza dog come on
um which is uh he's kind of crazy and a
car chase sequence that i mean we just
saw a car chase and it was freaking dope
so i can't wait for it to see all the
action here and of course marvel's hope
with kate bishop is that she could lead
potentially a future young avengers team
up as the hawkeye successor yeah and
we're gonna see how this series explores
the mcu after avengers end game like
trailers have shown footage of a
broadway show called rogers the musical
that adapts the battle of new york
events it's just starting to give us a
sense of how the history of the mcu in
that alternate world really affects this
universe's art and its culture and its
society it's gonna bring up a lot of
interesting conversations about what it
means to be just an average person
living in the mcu right oh my i love
that like perspective it's like i like
seeing how these gods like the actions
of these gods are affecting the regular
people i think that's what hawking is
going to give us for sure it's like my
favorite scene or one of my favorite
scenes in one division and in all the
mcu really was monica rambo uh blipping
back into existence oh my god
like that's i'm so excited to see
hawkeye show us these alternate
perspectives of characters just reacting
to these events we've only seen a god's
eye view of now we're just seeing it
from the people in the midst of the
chaos more shows like this um yes wink
wink daredevil come on let's get it
going um oh and of course tony dalton
joins this cast as jack du kong aka the
antagonist swordsman from the comics
antagonist avenger it's he's a really
interesting man he's known for playing
fearsome villains like lalo salamanca on
better call saul and averif amiga is
playing kate's mother eleanor bishop
though it's believed that she could be
revealed as the secret villain madame
mass because eleanor bishop and madam
mask are sort of linked in the comics
they are and like from all the trailer
imagery she's wearing like
this red gown and has like sharp cut
hair like she just seems kind of evil
right it's like shoot i'm clearly the
villain hair
she's rich
like she's rich
like all these things together just kind
of don't point in a positive direction
can't trust the one percent in general
we know that alaqua cox is playing maya
lopez aka echo who is a deaf native
american assassin with connections to
wilson fisk kingpin but she's also her
own badass warrior with skills and
abilities that mirror the combat moves
of any opponent similar to taskmaster
what taskmaster was supposed to be in
black widow and disney plus just
announced that she's going to get her
own mini series spin-off on this
platform meaning the mcu plans on
exploring her world and backstory more
in the spotlight now empty was
surprising to me that marvel would
commit to an echo spin-off before
announcing any future title for kate
bishop who's clearly the star of the
show from everything we've seen hayley
steinfeld's amazing has a bright future
ahead of the mcu but don't worry i i
think there are three clear takeaways
that we can embrace from this echo news
first off the theme of hearing loss
seems to me it's going to be pretty
important to clint barton and an
important piece of connective tissue
between these two characters and in fact
it makes us think that she's probably
gonna have some things to teach clint
about how you can use your other
heightened senses to your advantage
which brings us to our second takeaway
that reminds you of a certain vigilante
in the new york city area operating
without the use of one of his senses
yes of course how can we forget
frogman the strongest hero i love
frogmen sorry
[Laughter]
obviously we are waiting for daredevil
in the mcu and this is the side of the
world where daredevil matt murdock could
totally cross over because the character
of echo is just one of these street
level vigilantes who often cross paths
with him a lot of us are hoping that
either hawkeye or ekko maybe both of
them will start to feel like daredevil
season 3.5 or even daredevil season 4
perhaps even introducing wilson fisk
kingpin things like the hand stick matt
murdock daredevil in the mcu we've
pointed out before that the timeline of
the hawkeye series coming out on disney
plus is going to coincide with the
release of spider-man no way home that
movie is going to drop exactly between
episode 5 of hawkeye and the final
episode of hawkeye that's usually when
the big reveals end up happening right
and spider-man no way home has been
speculated for a while to include some
cameo by charlie cox maybe coming in as
matt burdock officially in the mcu we
don't know that for sure yet but maya
lopez does work for kingpin in the
comics her father was killed by kingpin
and her father will appear in at least
one episode of this season according to
casting reports and the third takeaway
marvel is probably holding back on what
will be a no-brainer kate bishop
spin-off or some other future title that
she'll appear in because they're just
waiting to announce what will be a major
thing
that could spoil some other plans that
they have in the works i'm thinking
either a young avengers series or a film
but i think it's more likely that
they're not even going to call it young
avengers it's going to be something like
avengers new legacy or something like
that i think kate bishop is going to be
a vocal character in it they're just
waiting to see how this show plays out
before they do that interesting now that
does make a lot of sense because like
they i mean these disney plus shows they
are you know kind of uncharted territory
so like you know disney's probably like
yeah let's see how people react to a
kate bishop and like and then maybe
we'll see how we integrate her moving
forward like announcing an echo spin-off
doesn't really spoil anything that might
happen with echo in the show i would
think and that's why they announced
they're not afraid to announce it now
but if you were to say like also we got
a young avengers show or something like
that like it means that the title
whatever title she's gonna appear next
is way bigger than just a kate bishop
show it's gonna be some kind of avengers
related thing and right now marvel's
like
let's hold off say anything about
avengers 5 or an avengers series
whatever that is uh until we're able to
introduce a few other parts a lot of
people are going to this hawkeye show
expecting hawkeye klim barton to be the
main focus because like that's who we've
known since the war ii and so like you
know obviously kate bishop is going to
be a factor in like we know that she's
going to be the next hawkeye a lot of
people probably have no idea like that
who bishop is and so they're probably
just gonna be like all right let's just
surprise them with like her being the
next hawkeye um by the end of the season
so maybe that's what they're holding up
for as well that's also possible there
could be like a second season where it's
just kate bishop you know but they don't
they don't want to reveal that yet but
that is pretty much where it's going and
like
kate bishop everything we've seen from
her in this promo material
she's just nailing this character like
the tone of it is so fun
such a talented performer and it's super
funny like i can't wait to see more of
her in this universe i think it's
perfect casting oh literally like she's
literally acting like kate barton from
the comics it's it's
one to one bishop bishop but we just
want to give all of you like a sense of
the different directions that mcu is
expanding right so it's obviously
expanding into the stars it's expanding
into the multiverse uh it's expanding in
horror directions right with like
one division with marvel zombies with
agatha house of harkness but it's also
just exploring into the street level of
the mcu uh organized crime uh characters
who were on the ground watching things
blow up in front of them and above their
heads and how that affected the society
in different levels and that's one of
the great things about marvel comics is
you're able to get all these different
perspectives uh and all these different
levels of stakes and it's really hard as
we saw in eternals to keep raising the
stakes with these apocalyptic world
ending events uh sometimes you can just
raise the stakes for just uh for just
characters
trying to
grow up into the next stage of their
life or a character's just trying to
cling on to what they still have the
fact that they're exploring this new
direction for clint barton with him
losing his hearing i i think is a really
really cool idea to explore oh
absolutely and like you know
it's just more like representation for
people with disabilities and like i
that's why i love with makari and like
with echo and with hawkeye now it's just
like you know deaf people are
being shown as heroes it's super dope
and like representation like this is
super important so good on you marvel
agreed morally
uh yeah it also like opens up all kinds
of cool ways to tell stories and and put
you inside the heads of people who see
the world and experience the world
differently than you do like that's
what's cool about it is it's like gives
us a new type of story to tell it's one
of the things i love about daredevil you
know uh so i'm super excited that going
in this direction but we have a lot we
want to talk about more things you
should know headed into hawkeye before
we get to those as folks are going back
to their offices we don't necessarily
want to give up that comfortable work
from home attire
you know that we've all gotten used to
uh i'm working for all my pants right
now
yeah we are not ready to switch into
these stiff and stodgy work attire yeah
you don't have to sacrifice style for
comfort though with cuts clothing
there's never been a better time to give
cuts clothing a try because cuts is
kicking off the holiday sale season
early with 30 percent off sight wide now
through december 3rd around the office
we're huge fans of their ao joggers that
are super comfortable but look sharp
enough to wear to work they also have
some of the best fitting shirts they're
known for their signature tee a bold new
take on the classic design it's buttery
soft which is a descriptor you want both
in your mashed potatoes and in your
comfy shirts
their collection of clothing for all
occasions and seasons includes polos
bomber jackets and more
ship again 2021 is coming in preparation
cuts is starting their sales season
early for you with 30 off site-wide
starting november 9th so that you can
have worry-free holiday shopping head on
over to cutsclothing.com today to get 30
off site wide through december 3rd and
upgrade your wardrobe with their world
famous shirts joggers or their all new
outerwear that's c-u-t-s
clothing.com also a secret source for
giving incredible gifts this holiday
season is uncommon goods they have
perfect gifts for all your moms your
dads your kids your in-laws besties or
that cranky next-door neighbor whose
heart you want to warm this holiday
season it's not stuff that you can find
just anywhere uncommon good says unique
and creative gifts often handmade by
independent artists and makers they have
gift guides to help you match the right
gift to the right person they have some
super cool gifts that new rockstars fans
would love like a scratch off movie
bucket list poster to keep track of the
movies you've watched or cool notepads
made out of recycled floppy disks who
knows what holiday shopping will look
like this season and the unique gift set
uncommon goods can sell out fast so shop
now and get it taken care of early
uncommon goods also offers uncommon
experiences choose from live online
classes in mixology cooking flower
arrangement embroidery and more from
hand pick artists and experts and with
every purchase you make at uncommon
goods they give back one dollar to a
non-profit partner of your choice to get
15 off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.com
marvel that's uncommongoods.com marvel
for 15 off don't miss out on this
limited time offer uncommon goods we're
all out of the ordinary now one thing
none of us want to be worried about is
the looming specter of a big old credit
card balance upstart can help lift that
burden and help you avoid the debt demon
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment unlike
other lenders upstart looks at more than
just your credit score like your income
and your employment history this means
they can offer smarter rates with
trusted partners with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars you can
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you load
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel and
guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can help give
you that confidence where it counts
bluetooth is unique online services it
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them any time date or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready for
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up by
bluetooth.com console with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so don't visit the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package so if you can
benefit from some extra comments when
it's time to perform bluetooth can help
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code inside marvel let's
check out just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
inside marvel to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring the
show all right we were talking a bit
about this before mt but let's dig into
it more what the hawk why is clint
losing his hearing and how important
will that be to the show i think
probably the destruction of avengers
mansion
is what caused clint to lose his hearing
because he's pretty much the only
non-superpowered or protected person
during the snap like it's only it's him
and the avengers and like it's just all
right i'm here um no protection very
little idi so like we just she probably
just got really messed up one of my
favorite you know hawkeye memories is of
course from avengers 1 when he does that
trick shot he doesn't even look and he
just hits that chatari i think that you
know hearing is a really big part of
aiming and it is a big part of how he
does his thing and so like if he can't
hear it's going to be a little bit
difficult so like you said he's probably
going to need to learn how to go really
focus his eyesight um in the coming
season and that's where echo is going to
come into play well if you go back and
watch in game which i was checking out
the the imax version that they released
on disney plus in that scene where hulk
is about to snap the gauntlet
clint barton is the only
non-super-powered individual in that
room who is not
who's not armored up in some way
so he's just there standing behind tony
stark shield um so yeah the snap happens
that goes down but then thanos bombs the
place and yeah like even uh scott lang
as he walked up to the windows you can
see closely he uh shrunk in the last
second into the armor as uh as the
explosion was tearing through the
building clint barton meanwhile was just
there unarmored unprotected in any way
so that's a pretty big boom boom and i
can imagine that like but the fact that
like hawkeye might revisit that moment
and just kind of explore like the
physical toll that it took on him that
this particular battle and remember that
particular scene like it makes me really
excited for the hawkeye show that this
isn't just a show that's going to like
move on from the mcu and just tell its
own thing and not care about the
interconnectivity it's going to be
deeply rooted in the way that loki seem
to be remember there's that opening
scene of loki that revisited endgame
right it seems like we may see something
similar in hawkeye where like people who
are obsessed with mcu and the way these
sequences played out are going to be
rewarded by watching the show as opposed
to watching it being like do they not
care about the mcu infiniti soccer that
came before
um it's one of my favorite things about
marvel that clearly every director that
comes on these things for the most part
is is super aware and super plugged into
what came before speaking of like you
know that time of when at the avengers
mansion crumbled right after that he was
chased by all of those thanos alien
monsters so like you gotta think like on
an emotional level like on a mental
emotional level this dude's scarred now
what's our next question empty uh well
what the hawk when does hawkeye take
place and where are the other avengers
like why is it just hawkeye and a random
uh
girl that he just found
yeah this is uh it's interesting because
we're trying to figure out when this
show is set and at one point there's a
set photo that says happy new year 2025
which means this is holiday 2024 which
means it's a little over a year
after
uh end game and one division it's after
the events of uh the falcon the winner
soldier it's after spider-man far from
home so this is um the furthest ahead in
the mcu that we that we've seen yet
basically
um so a lot of avengers are not around
first off anymore we don't know where
captain america is uh we were hoping
we'd see cap show up or at least get
referenced where he is in the falcon
winter soldier the fact that they didn't
makes me think
none of these disney plush shows are
gonna tell us the answer to that i hope
that uh in moon night kanchu's like oh
yeah steve rogers is over here he's on
the moon
yeah
yeah i mean right now the closest we've
seen steve rogers is in a free guy
at a coffee shop watching free guy's
fortnite game and then he reacted
we don't know where old man rogers is uh
tony stark's obviously dead natasha
romanov in this universe is dead uh
she-hulk seems to be telling us some
stuff about where bruce banner is
um but like he's kind of in his own
world he's in his own gamma lab so like
the avengers are all kind of scattered
and i think that's and hawkeye's always
kind of been in his own
little world like since we found out he
has a family in an age of ultron it
gives a convenient excuse to explore
hawkeye in his own bubble uh with his
own family drama or his own personal
exploits i mean even an end game he was
he was on his own track uh he doesn't
play well with others
more so than most of the other
characters
uh so it makes sense to see hawkeye on
his own here but i want to ask you mt uh
what the hawk this roger's a musical
that seems to be a big part of the show
in order for that to be the case the
avengers the living avengers would have
had to sign away their life rights who
do you think produced this musical
uh and how do you think this why is
clint barton watching this musical i
really hope it's kingo i really hope
that it's kingo just doing his thing and
he's because he loves musicals and like
he just loves the avengers so like if it
was it makes sense for kingo to to be
funding this um yeah i love that theory
i i hope i mean i guess that if they
don't want to be sued then like maybe
they have to sign away their life rights
i don't know but what do you think is
going on there i mean i guess you could
say they're they're public figures but
like even then i don't think you can
like
uh i don't know it's probably something
to where since they were avengers they
were too public by signing these uh
sokovia chords or part of clint barton's
fbi terms means that like people can uh
write stories about you fictionalize
your life in all kinds of ways and you
can't do anything about it but we'll
give you a free ticket to the show for
you and your family you bringing up
kangoo is a fascinating idea because
kingo in eternals talks about you know
as a filmmaker he was inspired by sprite
who was like a storyteller uh so like it
could be king could be sprite both of
them are pretty like active and as
storytellers could have like inspired
these things could be somehow part of
these things this is true and sprite is
an actor at one point in the eternals
comics he does have like his own tv show
like that's so sprite or whatever so
like
all right mt uh
so let's do it let's play some bets for
what we think the big twist of the
series will be so what the hawk who's
gonna be the man behind the curtain of
this series just as a reminder in wanda
vision it was uh agatha harkness all
along but we also got some teases of the
dark holds dr strange's multiverse of
madness etc and falcon winner soldier
revealed that uh sharon carter was the
power broker in loki we learned it was
kang finally got one right uh one for
three there uh and then and what if it
was like a mixture of a couple different
things we had ultron infinity uh but
then they also revealed that zola is
still alive and kicking and killmonger
ended up being a sort of villain at the
end of the series so what do we think
it's gonna be for hawkeye there's
there's all these rumors about you know
madame mask coming on and like it does
make sense um given that you know how
the mcu is moving forward with iron
heart um and we know that um madam mask
is a big iron man villain so and you
know everyone loves iron man so it makes
sense i mean it it from a marvel
studio's point of view you just put an
iron man character in there like you
know we don't really hawkeye doesn't
have a huge rogues gallery that people
know about so it's just like hey madam
mask why not and like madam ask was a a
huge component or a a component in a
very popular um section or story in the
matte faction run i'm in the comics so
it just makes sense um that you know the
creators of the show would probably be
inspired by those comics and like in
seeing that amazingly all right just put
on the show why not um what do you think
who do you think is going to be this is
the ripe opportunity for kingpin to show
up we bend the knee to kingpin we stand
kingpin we're gonna be looking for
kingpin and breakdowns and after shows
we're gonna talk about kingpin a lot get
used to it uh but a reach theory i mean
it's been a little bit since we've seen
scrolls don't you think like we just got
this announcement about secret invasion
from disney plus day secret evasion
despite it being about an alien
infiltration is kind of a more grounded
story the question of it is grounded
like who among you
who in the cubicle next to you who have
you been fighting alongside all this
time is actually a scroll imposter the
fact that we saw that track suit wearing
scroll on loki makes me think that
someone in the tracksuit mafia could
have been a skrull and that might be
like the way one division people forget
did have a scroll stinger didn't have
one post credit scene about scroll we
might get another one here just to kind
of tee up secret invasion uh because
otherwise we're gonna be looking to
things like uh to moon knight or to
she-hulk
uh it's possible that one of those could
include a scroll scene i think it's very
possible that miss marvel has a scroll
scene right it's almost guaranteed that
squirrels show up in miss marvel uh but
just to kind of keep keep it alive keep
it alive
keep an eye out for a squirrel somewhere
in hawkeye oh yes definitely we
definitely should be out for squirrel
watch anybody could be a skrull even one
of um hawkeye's family members could be
a squirrel who knows sure oh sure
watch out you never know
all the members of steve rogers the
musical
yes
no human can move that well right oh my
god i don't buy it finally the last
question of the day is what the hawk are
marvel's plans for the young avengers
because kate [ __ ] yes is on that team
kate bishop seems to be headed that
direction well we just learned that
philip scored an interview with tren
tran at marvel studios like one of the
top brass at the company she's been in
kevin feige's inner circle part of the
brain trust for years so uh thank you he
actually asked her a bit about this she
had some interesting things to say a lot
of us think that we're headed toward
young avengers you guys have a lot of uh
young cats that have joined the mcu now
including kate bishop who we've now met
who is so charming in the show are you
guys thinking that maybe a younger set
of superheroes is a way for younger fans
to be able to jump on board now without
having to go all the way back to iron
man 1 and know every little nugget of
the story i think the focus that we have
uh right now is you know because kate
bishop is new to the mcu let's make sure
we get her right in this series so i
think the focus at forefront is let's
make sure she's
you know done correctly so that there is
potentially yes room for anything down
the line but until we get her right in
the series there might not be anything
you know if
people don't love her so but i think
with haley she's
exceptional and she's so talented and
she brought a version of kate bishop
that we had envisioned for all these
years um and and now it's finally you
know getting the time to i guess shine
in the series aha
so you know what that means everyone if
you want to see kate bishop and young
avengers we have to stand the hell out
of this show yeah we gotta go to bat for
it we gotta make some beats we gotta use
some animated gifs we gotta be making
her trend on twitter every
wednesday wednesday i really wanna see a
young avengers project so let's all
watch all these shows the young avengers
in them so you can see uh the youths
save the day the children are the future
well that is it for this episode of
inside marvel we're gonna be back on
wednesday with our reactions to both
episode one and two we're gonna do them
in one episode since both episodes are
dropping day one on uh november 24th so
we'll be there with our reactions to
both episodes so we can't wait to join
you guys take your questions and uh jump
on those shirts you get to put your
we'll answer some of your questions you
know if you write in your custom shout
out uh so we're excited we're so excited
for hawkeye you can follow me at ea boss
follow mt at mastertainment follow new
rockstars and you can subscribe to the
inside marvel podcast feed wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
and we will see you after the premiere
[Applause]
you